look i know everyone is disappointed
that hogwarts legacy wasn't at the game
awards and trust me i get it i'm
disappointed too but i think there is
some pretty significant news that
dropped the day of the game awards and
not enough people are talking about this
so it's very possible that you
completely missed it but i think it's a
pretty big deal rhetoric and tour here
i'm just a dad who loves schemes and the
stories they tell and trust me you guys
i am definitely right there with you i
never in a million years thought we
would go the entirety of 2021 without
virtually any significant updates
regarding hogwarts legacy you know after
they delayed it so quickly in 2021 it
was clear we were going to be waiting
for a while but i really did not expect
this i completely get if you're
frustrated i completely get if you're
disappointed because we all wanted to
see a new trailer and there were some
things leading up to that in the day
that made it seem like it was actually
finally going to happen there's
absolutely still a ton of opportunity to
build hype and to get that marketing
campaign going because i definitely
think there will be a significant
marketing campaign behind this we did
just see that they finally hired a
community manager already made a
separate video on that so that's one
thing that's going in the positive
direction but right now i really think
it's the silence more than anything that
bothers the fans so if anyone from wb or
avalanche happens to watch this video we
don't want you to rush it's not that we
want the game rushed at all it's nothing
like that it's just we want to feel on
the inside a little bit we want to get
some updates on the progress i mean
after the game was first announced at
least we got tweets from the hogwarts
legacy account now they didn't even
tweet enough to where they had their
verified check mark removed this was
actually a thing you guys they caught it
over the harry potter game subreddit
there was a moment i think somebody went
back and looked where it was like one
year since they had last tweeted and
they hadn't tweeted anything at all so
they lost their verified check mark on
twitter for a while but it has since
been restored so that's a good sign but
for fans of the game it feels like it
really just doesn't exist right now
aside from a small interview comment
here or a concept art tweet there now
all that being said in the beginning i
did say we actually got some significant
news the day of in addition to the fact
that a community manager has been hired
but this i think this is even bigger
than that developer sumo digital had a
tweet go out the morning of december 9th
so the morning of the game awards and
here's what it says we are very excited
to share the news that two of our
studios red kite games and sumo
nottingham are involved in the upcoming
hogwarts legacy video game and then a
second tweet would go on to say they've
been hard at work with the teams at
warner brothers games and avalanche
software on a magical new adventure
under the portkey games label so for one
i absolutely love sumo digital they did
a phenomenal job with sac boy big
adventure it was one of my favorite
games last year my son and i had an
absolute blast with it but i think the
majority of people that worked on sac
boy were part of a different studio that
being said they're all part of sumo
digital so they they share resources and
i'm sure have a lot of back and forth
but if we want to look at the two
specific studios that they mentioned
here red kite games and sumo nottingham
we will find some interesting things so
first up this is the sumo nottingham
game page right here you can see some of
the games that they've worked on texas
chainsaw massacre and hogwarts legacy
both currently in development then
you've got forza horizon 5. major game
right there forza horizon 4 for steam
hotshot racing admittedly i'm not
familiar with that one and then team
sonic racing so a couple of quality
titles right there that they have had
experience working on and then if we
scroll through red kite games website
right here you see that they worked on
control ultimate edition mafia 3
definitive edition battle toads two
point hospital even god of war 3
remastered among a handful of other
games and so i think the interesting
thing that we can draw from this here is
that these are two studios with clear
experience behind them and experience
working with major ip that companies
like sony entrusted them with working on
something like god of war now i know
it's just like a remaster or definitive
edition whatever you want to call it
then with sumo nottingham you've got the
forza games i mean that is absolutely
huge now when all of that news broke we
got an additional tweet from sarah
longthorne who works with sumo digital
as a narrative designer so we're going
to pull up her tweet here where she says
well here's my first aaa game
announcement i hope those who choose to
play feel our collective efforts to
deliver something that entertains
inspires and delights but also welcomes
and respects all some additional tweets
i've worked with some truly incredible
people i can tell you now they really
care both about others and about making
this game the best it can be in all
respects to the best of their ability
and then the final tweet from her and
since it caused so much speculation
before yes this is the game referenced
in the 30 under 30 listing though others
are yet to be announced now credit to
sarah she was actually trying to answer
some questions from fans not revealing
anything about the game but she at least
responded on twitter here's one from ben
white who asks is there literally
anything you can tell us we've had radio
silence since the reveal and it's
breaking my heart she says wish i could
but no i'm sorry anything new you will
hear through official channels first now
i don't want to completely assume here
but if you look in her bio it says
previously hogwarts legacy and then just
going from the way that she talks about
the game here it sounds like she's
talking in the past tenses and her work
has wrapped up now if she's a narrative
designer that would certainly make sense
hopefully you would at this point you
would hope that all of that would be in
place and done now i'm not going to take
that and speculate any further from
there about how far along the game is or
where they may be but i will just say
from what she's saying here it does seem
like her portion is at least complete or
the part that she worked on with sumo
digital and there was another question
on twitter that kind of got to this a
little bit it said i know you can't talk
about the game don't want to get you in
trouble but i don't think this hurts the
game so i will ask it did you write from
the start or did you and the rest of the
studio join avalanche later in the
process she says sorry i would love to
answer but i don't think i'm actually
allowed to go into that right now either
ask me again post release so it probably
wouldn't be something that she could
comment on so now guys i know it's not
as extravagant as a new trailer but to
be completely fair we did get some news
on the day of the game awards and i
think this is significant so when you
take the news about the community
manager combine that with this things
are certainly moving in the right
direction towards a marketing ramp up
and to me i love the fact that we have
two very experienced studios here who
are involved with the project and i will
do a little bit of speculating here
because i think this speaks to the
magnitude of the game now back in may we
covered the dev interview of one of the
hogwarts legacy developers who worked on
the sound design for the game and he
talked about just how many people have
actually worked on this game now
unfortunately that interview was pulled
and it seems like he probably wasn't
supposed to say as much as he did but
one of the things that came from that
interview was he talked about just how
many people are working on this game and
so that's where my little bit of
speculation comes in i think it speaks
to how big this game is the fact that
they are needing significant help from
outside avalanche outside wb games and
we know wb has a number of studios that
could be working on this and helping out
as well we may not even know about all
of them yet but now we get this
announcement of sumo nottingham as well
as red kite games involved with the
project as well i think things are
certainly moving in the right direction
and as i mentioned before if this is a
holiday 2022 game as most of us have
expected there are plenty of marketing
opportunities throughout next year look
i'll be honest with you guys we have to
keep in mind that wb is a huge company
they have incredibly talented marketing
folks they've seen these trailer numbers
they know the power of harry potter
there's also that possibility that
playstation has some sort of marketing
exclusivity with this so that's just
another layer of planning that would
have to take place between multiple
companies now i also want to address
that rumor that wb is possibly concerned
with backlash related to jk rowling and
how they may be worried about how much
attention they want to draw to the game
look i'm not going to lie to you guys i
think it's certainly on their radar but
i'm not sure how much i buy this
particular rumor given just how heavily
they're promoting this hp reunion event
and fantastic beasts 3. we got a
fantastic beast 3 trailer coming by the
time you're watching this trailer has
probably already happened so it's very
possible that maybe they don't want to
show it at a gaming event where they
feel it might not be as well received
perhaps instead they show it at some
sort of harry potter themed event
instead and as i said numerous times
last year i think there's a great
marketing opportunity for 2022 just to
be an incredible year for the harry
potter franchise so we know fantastic
beasts three is hitting in april the
marketing is really starting to ramp up
for that maybe they use that sort of
march april time frame as kind of a
springboard into marketing for hogwarts
legacy after the release of fantastic
beasts three heck who knows maybe they
even show the next trailer before the
fantastic beasts three movie how
incredible would that be of course it
would be posted online and all that but
that would be a great opportunity to get
the trailer directly in front of harry
potter fans so i know we're all
frustrated we all want to see more we're
all kind of down and sad because
everything was pointing to the game
awards and it really seemed like it was
going to be there but i remain
encouraged guys i honestly do with the
passion of those who have spoken out
about this game and there's only been a
few but for those who have been able to
talk about the game the passion that
they speak about it and how excited they
are for people to play this and for
people to check it out that gives me
hope that it's going to be well worth
the wait and i expect that we're going
to start to hear more about the game in
early 2022. trust me given the parties
involved in the power of the harry
potter brand there will be a significant
marketing push when the time is right if
you want to stay up to date on all the
latest hogwarts legacy news theories and
discussion then check out the playlist
on the left side of your screen or if
you're in the mood for some old school
harry potter let's plays check out the
playlist on the right side of your
screen as always thank you all so much
for watching i'll talk to you again soon